welcome everyone to cfar's virtual talk
series
these talks are intended to share
research from across the academy
from computer science population and
public health to economics and
anthropology and many other areas
today's talk will be cfar's last talk of
2020.
if you're not familiar with us seafart
is a canadian-based global charitable
organization
that convenes extraordinary minds to
address the most important questions
facing science and humanity
my name is daniel bachinello i'm
director of research at cfar and it's my
pleasure today to introduce you to
heather graham
heather is a fellow in cfar's earth 4d
subsurface science and exploration
program
and research associate at nasa goddard
space flight center her research focuses
on looking for bio signatures in the
universe
and the topic for today's talk is the
search for life as we don't know it
before we begin i'd like to quickly set
the parameters today's session will last
30 minutes
i will take advantage of my position as
host to ask the first few questions
before opening it up to questions from
you the participants online
so if you have a question please submit
it through the q a function at the
bottom of your screen
lastly the session is being recorded and
will be available on the cfar website
next week so thank you so much for
joining us today heather
hello oh you're very welcome
so you're part of cfar's earth 4d
subsurface science and exploration
program
which as the name implies focuses on
studying the world beneath our feet
your work as an astrobiologist focuses
on looking for life on other worlds and
on
agnostic bio signatures so to start us
off
what are agnostic bio signatures and how
does studying the history of life on
earth
provide insight into the search for life
on other worlds
hi yeah so um before we get started on
what agnostic biosignature is i thought
i might back it up just a bit to let
everybody know what a bio signature is
because it sounds pretty fancy but what
it really is
is just a physical indication of life
either in the present or the past and
even though it's a fancy word it can be
something as simple as a footprint
a fossil is a biosignature but there can
be
really complicated biosignatures like
molecules that preserve in sediments
that tell us really specific information
about
what lived there in that
environment in the distant past what
kind of metabolism it had
and really specific information even
about its taxonomy how it's related to
life now
when we say agnostic bio signatures what
we're trying to do
is uh really be specific about the fact
that a by
that biosignature by design is not being
um related to life that we see here on
earth
we're trying not to make that assumption
that all life
in the possibility space of life
throughout our solar system is going to
have the same biochemistry
as life here on earth and i really love
the way you
um introduce that question because a lot
of how we do
this kind of very spacey sounding work
is by looking at the earth
and looking at the earth's distant past
a lot of astrobiology's heritage is
really in
paleobiology um because the the past on
earth was another world
we wouldn't even recognize it and we
certainly probably couldn't survive
um humans in a lot of the distant past
on earth
so when we talk about spacey locations
with like different pressures and
different chemistries in their oceans
that was this planet too so we can we
can
really investigate the possibility of
space of life
which is an agnostic biosignature by
looking into our own planet's history
so given that then heather how might we
expect life on other planets to differ
from life here on earth and how do we go
about looking for it
so that's a that's a good question too
and i think it really brings us back
into everything we learned from
paleobiology too
because life is um life is a
conversation with its environment
everything that exists that's alive
has a history embedded
in its many adaptations that it had to
make to get here
um you know if we look at a plant now
it's almost
unrecognizable to the very first land
plants that
we see in the church of scotland the
rhine
shirt um and so it's often hard to say
like how are these things related
and those were a product of their
environment those soils were different
everything was very different then
and so um so we can use those analogies
to really guide that question um
when we look at other worlds we can say
again like
what sort of analogous metabolisms what
energy sources
are available there um what solvent
sources are available there or even
um more specific things about
temperature and
and radiation which isn't always a bad
thing right that that could be
this power that we get from the sun as
well and so just use those kinds
of of really basic parameters of an
environment
to then say okay what is the possibility
space that life could have
in that kind of condition as well
all right so if we think then about our
closest planetary neighbor which is
mars we know that for example earth
hosts an abundance of life but we still
don't know if there is
or ever was life on mars so
how did these two planets diverge in
their evolution and what does that teach
us
about life so i love
thinking about mars not necessarily
mars as it is now when i think about
bio signatures and possibility for life
and if there's life
elsewhere because mars is a really
special case
um if we look in the past when
um life was first originating here on
this planet
mars wasn't terribly different from
earth
it had an ocean it's not that far from
the sun it was getting a good amount of
sunlight
um it had a protective atmosphere so it
didn't have the
radiation problems at the surface that
it does now that are really harmful
and it was it was colder but it's
basically like
earth's little colder sister far away
and so when we look back in time and we
see that
they weren't that different around the
time that we think life originated on
this planet it really begs the question
what was so special about earth that we
got to have life
now and mars didn't um
i think another way to think about that
is
just to really understand the
habitability space
that um is possible for life and
i in many ways it's even more exciting
that mars
is the way it is now because it it
allows us to really query
what is necessary for life when we see
something that was so
different then and and was so similar in
the past
i think um it's also really useful for
everyone to know that there's been a lot
of history between
earth and mars that we've been swapping
rocks back and forth for billions of
years
we have all sorts of meteorites which
aren't meteorites that come from the
asteroid belts but that are meteorites
from mars
and that's some of the really
interesting ways that we can have clues
into the past
of atmospheric and ocean history
on mars is through those meteorites and
so really
if you engage your imagination you can
you can think to yourself well we've had
life here for nearly four billion years
we've had four billion years of rocks
going back and forth
what broke on mars that they don't have
the the saturation of life that we find
on this planet
well so they may not have the saturation
heather but i guess the question is
is there life on mars
i love this question everybody wants
everyone wants a yes or no
and um i i guess what i'm really trying
to get at is that it's even more
exciting if it doesn't
um this planet has life everywhere it's
in the bottoms of the oceans you can dig
deep in the sediments that are beneath
the seas
miles deep and you'll find life you can
go in the clouds and find
life um everywhere you look there's
there's
new life forms and often even in
association with other
organisms there's this this complete web
on our planet um and so looking at a
place where there isn't life
answers as many questions um as
as looking for life on earth it really
tells us like oh what were the limiting
things
um between the two planets so i know it
sounds a little bit disappointing but
i'm
almost always even more excited to know
to see that mars doesn't have life i
also
should say that from a geologist's point
of view it's even more exciting to see a
planet
with light without life so that you can
understand a lot of the processes that
would be completely
physical there are all sorts of
processes on earth that have life as an
intermediary and so it makes it really
hard to understand
how would those processes look in a
completely abiotic sense because we
can't do those experiments here on earth
you try
and something moves in and next thing
you know you have a bunch of critters
um so we can look at weathering
questions
and and questions about mineral states
on mars in a very different way than we
can do those experiments
in environments here on earth where
inevitably something's going to move in
and add a whole new signal to your
system
indeed we have a lot of life here on
earth
so we've talked a lot i guess about the
similarities and the differences between
earth and mars but there is an enormous
diversity of worlds in our solar system
so what do those look like and would we
expect to find life on those other
worlds in our solar system
yeah so i think a really useful way to
approach this question is to first make
sure everyone knows
that as much as we like to talk about
water on mars
there is a lot of water in our solar
system
there are many moons in the outer solar
system which have extant oceans oceans
on them right now
and these are very different
oceans than our own they're often
encrusted in ice
and as far as we can tell
our ocean is the least salty ocean
in the solar system so this is where it
becomes really useful to stop
using biosignatures as we see them out
here don't use the templates of life on
earth to understand a completely foreign
ecosystem potential ecosystem on another
planet
because it is again living in a totally
different environment
and that that expression of life is
going to be dictated
by the environment it's in and the
adaptations and history of its
environment
i think this is something that makes the
earth 4d program
at seafar really useful and exciting for
this kind of
investigations of life in the outer
solar system
because a lot of the waters that we find
in the deepest parts of the earth that
many of the fellows in the program are
studying
are very very salty very briny
and those become great places for us to
test
equipment that we would like to send to
other planets
because those brines are far saltier
than the ocean they're like
10 11 12 times saltier than the ocean
so in order to test equipment it makes
it a great test bed
it also makes it a great way to test
energetics
of potential bio biological systems
or even the um stability
of certain molecules that we think would
be associated with life
which might have a very different
stability field in
a briny system like that so there's a
lot of practicality
in our in our research that we do in the
cfar group
for understanding the outer solar system
and it's really
um because of that presence of water and
oceans and the fact that our
subsurface oceans um
not oceans our subsurface waters here on
earth probably
um are a great test bed for those um sub
glacial or sub
ice oceans in the outer solar system
so you mentioned the search for agnostic
bio signatures which indicate sort of
life
in a way that doesn't look the same as
it does here on earth
so if we don't have a template here on
earth for it how do we know that what
we're detecting when we look for
agnostic bio signatures is in fact life
and not simply one of the many other
signals coming from the universe
yeah so i think the best way that i can
explain agnostic biosignatures
and in a way that might be more
comfortable for people who
who don't uh know a lot about squishy
life science and things like that or
microbes and all this stuff and
and are like give me the facts is that
life
is a perturbation of physics the most
basic thing that life is doing is
breaking
energy barriers that would be
unlikely in an abiotic system
that's really a function of what our
enzymes do
that's the business of the cells is
taking raw materials
and turning them into biomass or
or other materials for for metabolism
faster than they would happen otherwise
if it was just two random molecules
floating around waiting
to meet each other and react so that's
the real
business of life is breaking those
energy barriers
so what we like to say in agnostic
biosignatures is that we're
we're looking for um perturbations of
physics
uh some really concrete examples that i
can give you
of that goes back to our example of you
know molecules
meeting each other along the way and
reacting and synthesizing new
cooler maybe molecules is
complexity signals in organic chemistry
the stars and meteorites and spaces full
of fantastic organic chemistry
carbon-based chemistry
i know when we think of organic
chemistry we think of organisms
and biomass and you and me and all the
other critters but really
organic chemistry is happening all
throughout space
but there's very different patterns of
families of molecules that you see in
those systems
than if you look in biology and a lot of
that has to do
with the complexity and relative
abundance
of different molecules that becomes very
particular
in an organism where there's a great
over expression of certain things that
are hard to make
and that tells you life was there that's
not happening out in stars where it's a
little bit more
lego it's a little bit more polymeric
it's things getting bigger and bigger
and bigger
in this abiotic system of reactions that
are happening
really great example on this planet
would be chlorophyll
that's a fantastically complicated
molecule that's really hard to make if
you're not a plant
um but we're swimming in it and we have
way more of it than anything else that's
that's not the kind of uh chemistry that
physics would make
you can extend that same analogy to all
sorts of systems
you know where if you're even thinking
about elemental abundance
nature puts elements in different um
abundance patterns than life does and so
really that's what we're doing in
agnostic biosignatures
and that goes back to that other thing i
was saying is really
understanding your abiotic environment
is so
important so you know when you're
looking at something that's unlikely
and also you have a sense of what the
the energy barrier between this
strange thing you're seeing and the rest
of the environment are and that will
give you a clue
if it's truly something that's living
interesting and so i guess one of the
questions i have next
is does the search for life depend
on what our definition of life is and
what we consider to be life
yeah this this is a tricky question
because of course nobody can agree what
life
is right and um
and i i think one way that i like to say
that is like
physicists also don't describe what they
do they're like oh my gosh there's this
crazy new
you know particle we don't we don't know
what it is and nobody's like no
define energy what is that particle
so i feel like in life sciences and in
life detection
um it's okay that we don't have a
definition
of of what is the canonical part of life
and that's why i'm i'm just fine
saying life is everything that isn't
abiotic until you prove it otherwise
um because i think also we get really
trapped in this kind of taxonomy of
what's life and we miss out on a lot of
the really creative questions
and we really um damage the
possibilities of our own research
i think a really prescient example
that's probably on a lot of people's
minds right now and why we're talking
like this and on a coffee shop
is that you know by a lot of definitions
of virus
isn't alive and i'm not gonna wade into
that
fight because that's not my area um but
i think
by treating something like that as not
alive
you've already blocked out certain tools
that could have been adapted
for that study that would have been very
advantageous had there just been a
simple
taxonomic shift in how we think about it
and this is something that's very
important for us in in agnostic
biosignatures
is to never leave any tool behind um
just because it's something that we
don't use for detecting life here on
earth doesn't mean that it might not be
a good tool for using in the distant
past when we're trying to
understand life um it preserved
uh elements of life here on this planet
or in a completely different system
potential ecosystem like another planet
fantastic and so thank you heather for
sharing your insights and for answering
some of these first few questions
and i think perhaps now i'll turn to
some of the questions from the audience
so and this is a good segue from what
you just said but you've talked a bit
about how we
look back in time using earth or other
places as examples
so can you say a little bit more about
what you mean in terms of looking back
in time and
how it's possible to do that yeah
so that's a great question and i know it
sounds a little bit flipped to say
looking back in time and i think the
best example that i can give you is
geology is our window into the distant
past
um the the writer
ecologist rachel carson had a great book
that she wrote which nobody remembers
because silent spring was so great
but she wrote a book called the oceans
around us and one of the things that she
talks about
is the fact that the sediments um
are this constant snowfall in the oceans
that
are raining down weathered rock material
from the continents
from life that's in the oceans and
slowly building up this history
and eventually those oceans move on
we've we've seen
you know i'm sure everyone has seen old
globes of what the world looked like
when there was gondwana and other
you know super continents so it's no
surprise the oceans
aren't always in the same location over
the 4 billion year old history of the
earth
so what happens is those oceans see that
seabed becomes the record of what used
to live
there that happens in lakes that happens
in all sorts of different geologic
systems
and so that that package of geology
becomes that
time machine for going back and looking
and asking what
lived there you can do that just by
looking at the rock it can tell you
things like
was that water oxygenated or not because
certainly our oceans haven't always had
oxygen and our atmosphere didn't either
so we can tell really really um broad
questions like that when we look at
those rocks
or we can look at really specific things
we can look for specific fossils
um did that you know when did shells
arrive
shell on organisms was a massive
innovation and evolution of protection
for organisms when did those arise
or we can look at really super specific
things like a remnant of that
chlorophyll i talked about we find that
all over in the rocks
you know photosynthesis has been a you
know
a big industry on this planet and we can
find that in the rocks as well so that's
kind of what i mean when i say looking
back in time
interesting and so then to to take
another question from our audience which
really connects this to
to other worlds um
when you look at the earth what are you
learning through the earth 4d
programming through your studies here on
earth
about um about what the connections are
between earth and mars so like what are
you looking for
when you look at the earth that helps
you connect things to mars into the
development of habitability
yeah so um a lot of the research in the
earth 4d
program is really useful for
understanding mars as
it exists now as the planet exists now
and part of that is understanding the
habitability space
that is present on mars the state mars
in right now
is not great for most biology as we know
it here on this planet because
um without that protective atmosphere
and
um no magnetic field to deflect incoming
uh solar particles and cosmic rays
there's a lot of radiation on that
surface
which makes it really hard to run an
ecosystem
but that only goes down you know four to
ten centimeters
and then below that we know there's
water below that surface
and we know it's got some protection
from the radiation so then we can start
to ask questions about subsurface
ecosystems
and that's the kind of stuff going on in
the earth 4d program
this becomes a very different way of
thinking about ecosystems because if
everybody remembers you know the
kind of
relationships the web of life you know
you got your primary producers
and then you got you know something that
eats the primary producers the
vegetarians and then you get your tigers
that eat your vegetarians and that sort
of thing
when you're talking about below the
surface of the earth you got no
photosynthesis
what's your primary production what is
that first step
that fixes carbon into biomass
and allows any sort of ecosystem to
progress
what's the time scale that it takes to
develop that
and um what's really the mechanics of
living below the surface
everything that we're learning in the
subsurface program in cfar can really
help us understand
the subsurface of mars as a potential
habitat or
or um or even an extant ecosystem
yeah so then to lead from this i'm going
to go to another question from
from the audience um which is that we've
there's been speculation all over in
science fiction and in research about
life existing environments radically
different than on earth for example
purely non-organic chemistries or
nuclear reaction driven
driven life so do you think we have ways
right now to research
that possibility or is it clearly
impossible
yeah that's a that's a good question you
know and that's a that's a real question
right now
um because in i don't know now i can't
remember in six
short years um we're going to be sending
a spacecraft to go to titan
and titan doesn't have a water ocean
that's a hydrocarbon ocean think of it
as
like um rubbing alcohol or gasoline or
something like that
you know that's not a water ocean and
everything we see here on life
all this life on earth we see living in
association with water somehow
um and so that means that when we go to
titan we're really going to have to
either be thinking really hard about
refugia for life
that we're familiar with that needs
water or radically different chemistries
which would basically flip everything on
on its side
we live in in a water solvent enriched
environment water is in all of our cells
and then we take hydrocarbons
and build around the water um
to make our bodies microbes do the same
thing you'd have to flip that chemistry
on its side
on titan so that's that's a you have to
get really creative
in how you think about biochemistry and
this is where i think it actually
becomes really useful to start again and
i know this sounds boring looking at the
places where life doesn't live
um to to try and understand a little bit
more about what becomes
the the limiting of uh
factors for life to exist somewhere
because the real problem with not having
water
is something that does exist here on
earth not just in like oil spills
but um in brines where water is
much less available to an organism just
because a brine has lots of water
doesn't mean it's available
because all of those water molecules are
really being
taken up by all of the salts that are in
that water so it's actually a
a practical way of addressing that
question
thank you and so if we think about
i guess the earliest organisms that
appeared on earth they appeared very
early
in earth's history and so do you think
that means that
biogenesis so the emergence of living
systems
from non-living environments is highly
probable in the universe
and if so why do we not see it happening
all around us
it's a bit of a big question yeah
so this actually relates 100 to agnostic
biosignatures too
because i would spin that question a
little bit and i whoever
asked that question oh fantastic um
because we it's
you can't really say there's only been
one origin of life and that's
it right because we're using the same
metrics
all the time based on our own
biochemistry to say something is alive
versus dead that means if there was any
other sort of interesting biogenesis
that happened if there was any
other origin of life that happened would
we even detect it
since we expect it to have the same
biochemistry as our own
there could be there could have likely
maybe there were i don't know
many different origin of life events in
the distant past
and there's no reason to say that isn't
still happening
here on this planet but we have such a
narrow window of time
that we're asking these questions and
we've narrowed ourselves unnecessarily
in the metrics that we use to decide if
it's life that we wouldn't see it
and and equally those
sorts of biogenic processes could be
happening elsewhere
on this planet and on others yeah
and so then before we wrap up maybe i
can ask
one question which is could you comment
on your own
optimism based on your work about the
prospects for life
in our solar system or beyond um
where you think we're headed oh my gosh
yeah i always
uh you know i feel like this is such a
binary question there if you're like
no and then i feel like yeah it's
everywhere it's
groovy man and i feel like i'm just like
stalwartly um sanguine about this
question
um is there life elsewhere probably
like there's nothing unique that showed
up on this planet from
space this you know bunch of solvent
that couldn't have happened anywhere
else and all the oceans and all the
planets
you know ours isn't the only one but the
real question the thing that worries me
and keeps me up all
all night is would we know it if we see
it
that's a hard maybe until we get really
creative with our thinking
um in the kind of things that we're
trying to do in agnostic biosignatures
right now
all right and that that seems like as
good a place to end as any
i think that's fantastic and i think
your work will shed a lot of insight on
that
particular question so um that is all
the time we have for today though
before signing off i'd like to thank you
so much for joining us and i'd
especially like to thank heather
for sharing your insights with us please
visit our website
cpr.ca to find out more about this talk
series and to view
recordings of this and previous talks uh
the recording of this one
will be posted to our website next week
thank you again heather for
being here it's really a pleasure thank
you everyone